it's the summer
the travel the sun the sea and the big
phone bills from mobile roaming charges
meps have launched a new push towards
the complete abolition of roaming
charges by 2015.
this has become a kind of crusade for
meps demonstrating connection to
european voters
and driving towards the completion of a
single digital market
today a message to the telecom companies
that they have to follow our plans
because if they don't
work with us on getting rid of the
roaming
charges we will help them to do that
lithuanian cabinet ministers have been
lining up in parliament to put details
to the ambitions of their six-month eu
presidency
they follow on from ireland in theme as
well
with the economy minister evel das
gustas promising a drive for
competitiveness
and innovation with croatia having just
joined the eu
foreign minister lina slinkevichus
concentrated on engagement and
enlargement due east
we are spending a lot of time
legitimately a lot of time discussing
issues in the hot spots syria mali
somalia
spending all days until midnight and
this is legitimate as i say
but we shouldn't forget that vision of
europe whole and free not by far not yet
implemented
it's the most complex file he's ever
handed as chairman of parliament's
internal market committee
the file modernizing procurement of
public contracts
energy transport postal services among
them voting has been pushed back to
september to allow three separate but
interlocked directives to be written up
we think there needs to be more
cross-border activity
more competition but we need to
encourage the innovative companies and
the providers who've come up with
great solutions to deliver services
cheaper
and better and satisfy their citizens
better as well